[Music]
I'm Jeff glor from CBS Saturday morning
welcome to the dish we're firing up the
grill in today's episode and visiting
some of the best barbecue joints famous
for their Smoked Meats we introduce you
to a master of Carolina pulled pork
serving up as Savory Whole Hog specialty
and a self-taught award-winning Chef
takes us along the culinary journey of a
16-hour smoked brisket but first we get
a taste of the Lone Star States a Texas
barbecue Pioneer opened his restaurant
in the 1950s and now his grandson is
keeping the flame burning Janet shamlian
visits davilas for a bit of their
barbecue grilled cheese and signature
slow-cooked lamb
41. I got you I got you guys in the city
of Seguin there you are
davila's barbecue is destination dining
see and it's Destiny for Adrian Davila
this is where I'm in my my element the
most is
fire meat
he's a third generation Pit Master
started the restaurant in an old
cooking in front the family living in
back
whenever you're trying to live up to a
such a legend as my grandfather was in
the community as far as the barbecue
space like he was his Grandmaster
because he didn't leave the pits every
stick of wood every piece of meat every
sausage that was hung is him his
decision only nobody else touched the
pits so that barbecue always came out
with his stamp on it and you felt that
responsibility absolutely my hairs are
standing up right now you still do I
still do Raul dobbler was a butcher by
trade
indelible memories for Adrian I remember
him taking something that the time was
so Primal as a big cut of meat and
breaking it down and making something
beautiful with it and when it came out
under the table and people enjoyed it
that was astonishing to me Adrian's dad
Edward took over in the mid 90s making
his own mark thank you sir
46 but never asking his son to work in
the family business the j-46 yeah okay
envisioning something better even though
it's all Adrian wanted when again I was
able to see what it created and how you
created memories with food birthdays
celebrations anniversaries weddings you
create memories and I just that that
hooked me all right guys
culinary history
all right yes this is the ranch
by the Carol's Mexican cattle herders
Davila took us to his Ranch this is what
we call a barbacoa
for a look at how they slow cooked meat
like this lamb in an underground pit to
see the magic happened
you know how they have like oh my
goodness a tradition he's keeping alive
today
look at that is that ready to eat
when it's falling apart like that
there's nothing but
you see the seeds of the Tomato the
onion and the jalapeno the carols would
celebrate like this Davila says
an outdoor Feast at a colorful table
takes a lot of love and passion to
create all this and that's what makes it
so satisfying
oh okay
influenced by the past but with an eye
to the Future Adrian now runs Davos
that means new items like the barbecue
grilled cheese sandwich chopped brisket
sauteed onions just a little butter on
there huh Texas toast and lots of cheese
get every little bit in there you have
to try this okay this is now one of the
best selling on the menu
um
that's unbelievable
can we sell more of these per day
then we do our regular barbecue
sandwiches really imagine that as if we
needed more Davila prepared for us just
about everything he sells their
Signature Sausage still hand tied every
day
this is exactly the way my grandfather
made it not changing the recipe ribs are
a barbecue staple and almost always poor
but here they're Leia go ahead and have
a short bite okay
and then the vinegar of the pickle is
what you got to follow up with Chase it
right into the sauce
dessert is big red cake let's have a big
red cake do you do this to go yeah yes
one of our biggest sellers right there
really oh yeah made with soda of the
same name a tribute to his grandparents
my siblings and I would go to Grandma
and Grandpa's house there was that big
red cake in the fridge it's our favorite
thing for Adrian Davila it's always been
about family for his wife Sarah his
inspiration and teammate to the men who
held the title davila's Pit Master
before him
I was watching your dad watch you and
you couldn't see it but I saw the pride
in his eyes
so proud of you
well we all want right we're born with
this inherent trait to satisfy our
parents it's human everybody wants it
satisfy their parents right everybody
wants to make their parents proud
Proud Family Legacy
davolos one of a kind
up next chowing down at the destination
for a Whole Hog Barbecue this is the
dish
[Music]
when it comes to barbecue salt acid and
smoke or a recipe for success that's
proved true for Chef Rodney Scott a
James Beard award winner and barbecue
Hall of Fame inductee his talent for
Whole Hog Barbecue has taken in from his
family's tiny store to one of the
culinary world's highest honors Jamie
wax traveled to South Carolina for a
taste
very early in the morning here in
Charleston South Carolina
and the smell of wood smoke perfumes the
air
Rodney Scott is busy supervising The
Hive of imposing grills at what has
become a major destination for the
culinary art that has made him
internationally famous Whole Hog
Barbecue I wish the people watching this
at home could smell this place it's
unbelievable thank you it'd be
smell-o-vision
[Laughter]
Rodney Scott has been cooking Whole Hog
Barbecue since he was just 11 years old
yeah
at his family's Variety Store in the
small South Carolina town of Hemingway
from that time till now obviously you've
grown as a chef and a restaurateur but
has the process changed at all I am
definitely doing everything the exact
same way that I did it when I was 11.
it's just different equipment
so I still burn the wood down yeah still
take the hot coals and put it under the
hog and I still season the hog pretty
much the same way I mean it's an obvious
thing but but when I read your
description of what Whole Hog really
means as far as flavor it makes a huge
difference because you've got parts of
of the hog that are gameier parts that
are fatty or parts that are leaner and
you make something brand new when you
mix them all together right yeah when
you put them all together you get
different bites from different areas of
the hog you know we describe our
barbecue as a difference you can taste
and what we mean by a difference you can
taste is you have ham you have loin
you've got belly you got some shoulder
and when all those areas are combined it
adds up to one bite that can only be
described as Perfection all right that's
very hot all right I'll try and pick a
good piece okay I'm gonna join you there
oh my God
honestly best pork I've ever tasted in
my life that's part of my technique to
break it up so the seasonings can go all
the way through it and when you turn it
over to pull it you have everything in
there you see that it is true the salt
the acid the smoke it's all perfect in
that one bite but that one bite was only
the beginning and he looked like he had
his legs crossed I joined him for lunch
surrounded by an incredible spread of
some of his most popular dishes from his
book Rodney Scott's world of barbecue
it's part cookbook part autobiography
there are worse jobs than sitting out in
the South Carolina breeze with the
master of Carolina barbecue and this
beautiful table so all the dishes on the
table are pretty much a layout of my
life from the pulled pork where it all
started Grandma's cornbread what I
remember from being a kid the ribs which
I've come to love along with the pulled
pork
collard greens which I was a little
reluctant to eating but I do eat them
now my mama's banana pudding and the
dishes that are just introduced to me as
a Barbecue Pit Master later on was
brisket looking at this layout of his
life it's hard to forget that the road
to Pit Master started at such a young
age what is 11 year old Rodney Scott
like 11 year old Rodney Scott wanted to
go to a basketball game the work had to
be done before you went anywhere this
particular day it was a hog had to be
cooked and the challenge was laid out
you're gonna cook this hog before you go
anywhere and I made sure not to burn the
hog and when they flipped it over I was
like good you could pull the bone out
like it's supposed to it was done all
over
think I can do this others agreed in
2009 Scott captured the attention of a
New York Times food writer who wrote an
article that changed his life forever
people decided to say hello and
strangers started to say hello are you
that guy from The New York Times and
phone calls from different newspapers
and magazines started to interact with
us and I thought it was huge the Acclaim
LED Scott to finally accept the offer of
investor and restaurateur Nick tahakis
he opened his own restaurant in
Charleston which led to another
remarkable achievement they come in and
they tell you you are nominated for the
James Beard award what did that mean to
you at that time when we got nominated
for the Beard award it was unbelievable
to walk up on that stage and look back
out at all these great chefs and these
people in the food industry to be
recognized as you know best chef
Southeast was one of the most humbling
moments I've ever experienced Scott's
growing success coupled with leaving the
family business Works into long-existing
Rift between him and his father
something he writes about with startling
frankness in his book which was
published shortly before his father's
death I wish I could have had a real
conversation about why he was so opposed
to the things that I was doing that he
wanted to kick me out of the business
kick me out of the family too
in this book you write an incredibly
powerful section about the relationship
with your father how did that come about
and and what did it feel like to put
that down in writing this was years ago
that me and my dad did not agree on a
lot of things and in doing that having
that conversation for the first time
to say I'm going to tell the world this
is what I experienced was one of the
moments that the tension the not
sleeping well just kind of
went away because I felt like it's gone
the load is off my shoulders
letting go for Scott has led to a sense
of gratitude for each day it's the
philosophy he literally wears across his
chest every day is a good day I always
say if you're not in the obituary
section you got a good day you know you
got a chance to create the mood the
feeling that you want to have throughout
that day you have an opportunity simply
because you survived
and Beyond just surviving Scott is also
focused on what's next what are you most
excited about looking at the future of
Rodney Scott
trying to spread our barbecue all over
the entire world everywhere
that's my goal
still ahead West Coast style barbecue
with Southern Roots we're talking
brisket with all the fixes
self-taught Pit Master Matt horn is
earned top honors for his skills on the
grill he credits family traditions for
teaching him to produce smoked brisket
so sought after people have waited in
line for hours to taste Dana Jacobson
joined him for a full spread outdoor
barbecue in California
that draws customers in droves we just
hit our brakes furiously when we smelled
the goodness coming out of this place
horn barbecue in Oakland this one right
here since opening it's been known for
both its snaking lines
gotcha and mouth-watering meets and
sides I'm going pulled pork I might get
the pit beans maybe some mac dubbed West
Coast style barbecue its roots are in
Texas and the South the best barbecue
I've had outside of Texas
oh this is like our primary uh cut of
meat this is what everybody lines up for
so this is
this is the brisket
for Pit Master Matt horn barbecue isn't
just the finished product it's a journey
the smoke will come and it'll go right
over it from prepping and seasoning the
meat
just stoking the fire that brings it to
light barbecue is more than just
throwing logs in there and that sort of
thing it's very careful fire management
you know you have to maintain that
temperature we usually smoke our
briskets for about 14 to 16 hours it's
definitely a commitment you know it's a
labor of love
and appreciation horn learned along the
way I mean in the beginning I'm just
like okay I want to hurry up and finish
the cook and you find yourself popping
the lid and looking you know what I did
was I started to realize that throughout
the cooking Journey you want to trust
the smoker to do what it was built to do
be one with the fire
be in the moment be present and that's
what I've learned to do
this is the finished product right here
patience is now a virtue for horn but
not for me Matt I'm drooling can I
please take absolutely
there you go enjoy
it melts in your mouth
oh my God I'm gonna be very unlady like
I have to taste this jalapeno cheddar
right yep jalapeno cheddar I got a full
spread to sample in a backyard barbecue
starting with homemade jalapeno cheddar
sausage links I used to always see my
grandfather eat in the hot wings he
would take it right off the grill and he
would grab a piece of white bread and
just write it would just do it that way
that nod to family in everything from
the smoked chicken pulled pork and ribs
to the pit beans collard greens and mac
and cheese Grandma he says gets credit
for the dessert you gotta have banana
pudding oh
this is delicious like the barbecue he
serves Horn's journey in it can be
traced to Childhood when his grandfather
was the Pit Master whether it was a
wedding a funeral a birthday or just a
family gathering you know you'd always
smell the smoke the fire be lit and
there'd always be a barbecue in his
early 20s cooking became Horn's escape
from his day job he soon realized it was
even more not only did it give me
purpose but I felt fulfilled with what I
was doing in my life finally for the
first time in my life once I decided
that I want to start cooking you know it
was a clear choice that I wanted to do
barbecue because that was the thing that
brought us together as a family to hone
The Craft to barbecue horn turned to
Where it All Began I would drive down
from Los Angeles every weekend to my
grandmother's backyard and I'd take a
notepad and I grab a few cuts of meat
and I would fire the pit up and I would
take extremely extensive notes your
grandfather's pet oh yeah and that was
the only place where I can really
barbecue after a few months in the
backyard with family taste testers horn
headed to a farmer's market to sell his
barbecue I had about a little under a
couple hundred bucks and I bought as
much meat as I can with that and I just
literally believed in like hey if I
don't cut corners and I contribute love
and commit myself to this someone will
connect with it and we went through the
farmer's market for a year
and we struggle I even begin to question
am I doing the right thing what changed
your mind I took a few days off and I
didn't cook at all and I found myself
laying in bed
thinking about the smoke the fire all
these beautiful elements that make
barbecue what it is and I'm just like
you know what I have to continue to push
forward with this that feeling was
validated when horn launched his very
first pop-up barbecue I sat in my truck
and I was really emotional why because I
was grateful that they even came to even
to enjoy the food and then the next
puppet we had was 50 people there and
then the next one you know over a
hundred but little did I know that it
would turn into what it's turned into it
was one of the largest pop-ups in the
country and hundreds of people waiting
hours I mean I mean I can't even yeah
and they would set up their lawn chairs
they would set up tents people do that
for sporting events you've got
nothing and it was a beautiful thing and
I always made it an effort to go out and
Shake everyone's hand and thank
everybody for coming no matter how long
it took
when his restaurant became a reality in
the same area where his pop-ups became
legendary
made sure to include reminders of his
journey including his smoker Lucille
there from the start her name a tribute
to the iconic BB King song depend on
Lucille
I would find myself in all these
different places
farms at breweries and parking lots
alleys whatever
sitting there by the fire I'd have
Lucille by BB King playing every single
time there was always something about
that song that always made me uh
I don't know it always connected me back
to the purpose of why I do what I do
with barbecue
he says it's his way of giving love
something he's getting back in return
this thought that I had
to commit myself to cooking it's brought
me to where I am here now you know and I
wish both of my grandfathers was here to
just see like hey you know what that
thing that brought our family together
the thing that we've all connected to
I've taken that and I'm sharing it with
my community and
we're getting the recognition for it and
we're grateful
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Jeff glor
we'll see you next time for another
helping of
the dish
foreign